the comeback hit struck again last night
arroyo and braduco were two of those red
sox directly responsible for win number
39 as the sox go for two in a row over
toronto on a saturday afternoon that is
nick pavetta 6-1 one man down for bull
bucket
bo buchet swings at the first pitch that
he sees from pavette and sends her to
back up the box into center field for a
one out single here in the top of the
first so now the first at bat of the
afternoon for vladimir guerrero again
three for four including a double and a
home run
first pitch swinging and he drives it to
deep left center field and he has done
it again
he picks up right where he left off last
night home run number 20 on the season
for guerrero bonnie guerrero playing in
his 62nd game has reached a 20-home run
plateau
and that's going to get him right among
the leaderboards for blue jays franchise
history to the quickest
with 20 home runs here's the 1-2 pitch
wave dad and misty struck him out with a
curveball 3-2 on the
way endeavors will scoop it rafael on
target
side retired but vlad guerrero junior
strikes again it is a tough lineup and
stephen mats knows all about it he faced
the red sox on a 20th of may in dunedin
1-2 fastball swung on and missed
2-2 and he got him swinging elevated the
fastball and it's a very nice three up
three down with 2-2 pitch in there for
strike three
popped up near the mound and it'll be
the catcher going out and dropping the
ball
vasquez went out and had a difficult
play
going out towards the mound pavetta
initially called for it none of the
other infielders got in in time
now kavanaugh drills the first pitch to
deep right and it'll skip up into the
seats on a bounce
bizio with a double panic will stop at
third
the center field on the move hernandez
he'll make the catch
panic tagging up
and here's the throw the tag got him
launching from center field
and cuts down panic so it remains two
nothing toronto bottom of the second
inning and lying the other way for a
base hit off the bat at devers all the
way to the winning track hernandez
and a lengthy single and a good way to
start the second inning for boston
and now they got him in a rundown
and we'll throw him out devers was going
to second match through behind him
guerrero throws down to second and they
get him
3-2 runner holding
right back to matt's and he'll throw it
into the outfield
boy you see that so often renfro easily
down to third
[Applause]
on the slope of the hill and a misfire
and that's why they don't let pitchers
catch pop-ups right there to tell you
mats 2-2 and he got him that time right
over the inside corner for strike three
called and the 3-2
popped him up
maguire looks like he has a play in foul
territory and he'll make the catch
3-2 swing and a miss boy he chased a
breaking ball way down and in and matt
strikes him out again
and now he chases a curveball in the
dirt not a good at bat for devers and
mats now with six strikeouts already on
the afternoon
oh two lifted in the air left center
field they converge and it'll be tayoska
hernandez the left fielder to make the
catch division
ripped the first pitch that he saw in
his first at-bat for a double
oh one another curve and bisho gets it
in the air left center field and this
one is gone
up into the monster seats an opposite
field home run for bisho number four on
the season and it is three to nothing
blue jays fourth home run of the season
and it's another breaking ball and stays
out over the plate that's a great swing
by kevin right there back to the top for
marcus simeon
and he sends the first pitch
high and deep to left field and gone
another home run for the blue jays their
second of the inning third of the ball
game and it is five to nothing simeon's
got a reputation of being
a stronger fastball hitter than a
breaking ball hitter but boy he waded
back and rip that breaking ball it's 2-0
on boba's shed as the blue jays have
extended the lead to five to nothing and
still nobody out
and now beshett drives one to deep left
field and this one's gonna go as well
a no doubter for boba
third home run of the inning for the
blue jays and it is six to nothing
and both crushes it
my oh my he hit this one a long way and
you remember earlier this season he hit
one deep over those seats and that would
clear the seats as well
bounded to the right side nice play by
dalbeck underhand flip and pivetta there
in time to get him for the first down in
the inning
3-2 hit hard
knocked down by devers gathers guns
close and got him
backhand
clanked off his to heal but he got to in
a hurry and he threw a seed
breaky ball got him
he wanted to walk he'll strike out
instead but they also get three home
runs and they score four times
swing and a miss got him with a curve
ball down seven strikeouts
now for matt's
is loading it up there's a deep drive
left center field that's way back there
and that ball is going to be off the
wall
dalbeck racing around he's heading into
third he's going to get there he ate up
big chunks of real estate on his way
into third base and the red sox finally
have a guy down there
oh two back to the curve ball and a
swing and a miss to get him two down
how about this pop-up for beshet at
shortstop and what a job by stephen mats
and as brandon brennan his red sox debut
claimed off waivers from seattle in
early may aside of worcester
lines the first pitch into right for a
base hit
panic shoots one the other way for a
base hit teles up to second
chopper back towards the mound and it's
just going to die on the grass over near
the first baseline
saucedo picks it up when it stops moving
and that'll be an infield hit for biggio
to load the bases
cut on and misty struck him out and
brennan with a 3-2
on the way to simeon
hard ground ball picked up he'll tap the
bag got the out there on the first and
well done by devers
getting out of the inning couple men on
for vasquez well big fly here the red
sox are right back in it one two and
there's a looper into left field that's
going to drop down for a base hit here
comes the run
devers in to score and the red sox are
at last on the board here in the sixth
inning castro a guy who as relatively
inexperienced as he is
has really impressed charlie montoya
pete walker they are comfortable with
him
runners go again 3-2 got him
slider over the inside corner to freeze
him
one two and he got him a fastball up and
in and castro strikes out dalbeck
and did he go yeah he did well executed
pitch gonzalez couldn't check the swing
thrilled him and down goes kk and the
helmet goes flying
and is he okay
that was a 96 mile an hour fastball
he is up
cora is out and now with two down and a
runner on it'll be tim meza in for the
blue jays
oh two and a ground ball panic hazard
feeds pachette at the bag they will
force the lead runner and that'll end
the inning martinez with the lead off
second nobody out and a 1-1 home
as a bullet that's a fair ball guerrero
couldn't make the play that would have
taken his glove with it martinez in the
score
rounding second rafael devers easily
into third base three bases for him
and it's six to two two two
caught out at second
a great play by simeon and they'll
double off devers in third maguire who
is over two of the walk today
maguire turns on one and hits it toward
the right field corner it's gone
rhys maguire with his first home run of
the season and it's 7-2 blue jays
let's see if he can finish him off right
here and
secure this victory
one two on the way and he got him
swinging a miss at a fastball and the
blue jays will win it romano gets the
red sox in order in the bottom of the
ninth guerrero hits his major league
leading 20th home run one of five home
runs hit by the blue jays today